as chair of the house Public Works and
highways subcommittee on laps extensions
I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-4 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically these are presentations
pertaining to the lapse extensions
contained in the capital budget please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporary ly to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has a has access
to contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting notice complies with house
rules and RSA 91a anyone who has a
problem accessing the meeting should
email LBA fiscal ledge. state.
n.us in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled I want to
introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting us Christopher Shay
and Scott Shannon both from the LBA and
I see Brad Greenland the committee
researcher as well uh please note that
all vot votes that are taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
I'm not anticipating taking any votes
other than starting the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
State whether there's anyone in the room
with you during this meeting which is
required under the right to no law and
with that Mr clerk if you
would thank you Mr chair I'm going to
start with the uh
original uh uh signed attendees to this
uh committee please uh representative
Jack I am here here alone in my home in
nashwa representative Mills I am here
and my wife is somewhere in the house
representative
query I am here uh in Manchester at home
alone representative
Newman yes I am here in NASA my husband
is in the
house thank you that uh Mr chair that is
everybody who is assigned to this
committee um I've also noticed the other
some other people have signed in and I'm
going to include them in our list of
attendance representative
cluder yes I'm here here I'm considered
a non-voting Observer today but I'm here
just to to learn because of not only
being on the on public works but also
the capital budget overview committee
representative Edgar thank you
present I'm home alone uh thanks for
letting me participate I uh although I
guess I can't vote but I'm I'm here to
learn so thank
you uh representative
fidi I'm here my wife's in the house
somewhere in
hillsbor could you hear me yes I can
thank you uh Mr chair oh I'm sorry
representative
Peterson
here home alone I'm here to learn
through
osmosis all right uh Mr chair as far as
I can tell uh that is everybody who is
in attendance from public works and
highways and
um I guess I do have a question as as
far as I knew in the past anybody that
attended the
meeting as part of the committee was
able to vote
yeah we'll allow anyone to uh make
statements ask questions uh there the
there won't be a vote we will simply
report what we find back to the full
committee at at the work session on
Tuesday okay thank you the purpose of
this subcommittee is to go carefully
through the lapse extension portion of
House Bill 25 to make sure that it is
absolutely
accurate if we fail to lapse extend an
appropriation it will lapse on June on
at the end of June and the agency then
technically wouldn't be able to pay a
bill for that project that came in later
so it's critical that we identify every
uh lapse extension that needs to be made
conversely if there's a project that is
going to be done by June 30th and all
the bills are paid the agency will be
able to identify that for us and we'll
be able to reuse that money on some
other project I have done a a hand go
through of all the uh materials that
were provided ahead of time and I see
very little money that uh that that
would apply to uh
so if there's no questions on what I've
said uh we can start we with the with uh
our first agency is going to be
administrative services and that starts
uh if you're looking at the laps
extension worksheet it's on page one uh
item number one if you're look you can
also follow along on House Bill 25 and
it's item number one in the laps
extension section so as we go to the
agencies I will uh call out where we are
so if seeing no questions uh
commissioner Arling house I I do have
one comment uh you didn't uh provide
anything ahead of time have you cross
checked uh to make sure if we go if we
reference through House Bill 25 uh
that's not a methodology that will
identify anything that's
missing are we confident that you don't
have any item that needs to be extended
that's missing yes um uh we did that
okay great so we were um we're as
worried as you are um last thing we need
to have is Karen get halfway through a
building and go hey there's no money for
the windows um and we are pretty sure
that there
are let me rephrase that we know there's
nothing missing um what I'd like to do
with your permission is is go through um
we've got a long list of projects I
don't want to I don't want to be tedious
but um Karen is gonna start Karen ramaki
is the director of plant and property
right for us um for you for the state um
for all of us um and she's going to go
through the the construction is projects
and then at the end I'm going to talk um
and I'm going to try not to add
editorial comment um but I can't make
any promises um and then I'm going to
talk about the the IT projects which
there are four of that I'm going to hit
you with so okay we have 40 Projects and
about 40 minutes to do them so we need
to move Karen you're on the clock uh but
not okay we'll be fast Ken ramaki is
recognized good morning everyone
everyone thank you for the opportunity
to speak this morning um please feel
free to ask questions as I go through as
Charlie said we'll try to go through it
quickly but I don't want to overlook any
details if you have any questions on
anything so starting um as mentioned
with item number one um that is the
Statewide emergency
fund there is um about $1.2 million left
in that um and um those funds are used
as needed for emergency projects that
arise over the course of the
B item number two is the Walker building
hbac repair and replacement project um
the money has been encumbered in total
and the project will be completed in
June of
21 item number three is the state house
basement fire protection project which
has not yet started um I'll just stop
here briefly and say that there were
quite a few projects that were delayed
due to the p mic um so there are there
are quite a few things that are getting
just getting up and running now and will
be completed later in uh calendar 21 um
and into fiscal 22 and 23 I think the
committee knows that um the the governor
during the early days of the pandemic um
put a put essentially a capital budget
freeze and we didn't do there were in
the construction world we did a lot of
nothing for a lot of months while people
were you know understandably very skit
about where the budget and revenues and
all of that uh was going and um Karen
and her team were very frustrated on
occasion because I wanted to get out
there doing stuff and we were we were on
hold is why there's so many projects
this year sorry I'm done
interrupting thanks thank you um item
four is the store street parking garage
repairs um that project is getting
underway this month constructionwise and
is due to be completed in December of
21 item number five is for the State
House Annex Renovations we're currently
working with Architects on the design of
this and this will be a long-term uh
project going into the next couple of
years item number six is the State House
Annex elevator upgrades again this is
one that has not yet started um but we
be starting hopefully uh this spring or
summer
item number seven again um a project
that has not started is for several uh
conquered buildings roof Replacements
and exterior um building
repairs uh item number eight is for the
temporary boiler steam infrastructure
removal so these boilers were part of
the conquered steam conversion project
the boilers have been removed and most
of the infrastructure has been removed
we'd like to use the remaining funds to
pave the areas where the temper boilers
were to restore the property back to its
original condition and that will happen
this
summer item number nine is um 29 Hazen
Drive Health and Human Services and Dees
mechanical Replacements again this
project has not yet
started item number 10 is for raising
the structurally deficient conquered
steam building um I don't know if
anyone's had a chance to drive by lately
but that I I drove by yesterday the
stack is um coming down it's the last
piece that of the the existing building
to come down um phase one will be
wrapping up here in the next month or so
and we'd like to use the remaining funds
for phase two which will be to stabilize
the property um that remains so there's
a big
um uh drop off there um where you know
going down to where the building used to
be and we need to make sure that we make
that safe for the remaining uh tenants
that are on the
campus uh item number 11 is for
emergency backup generators for the new
boilers that were installed as part of
the conquered steam conversion project
um that project is set to wrap up in
September um and there's a couple
there's two other projects further down
that tie in with this project so I just
want to point that out and I'll mention
it again when we get
there um um item number 12 is annex One
Life Safety and Ada improvements this is
um to build an ADA connector um over at
the Annex Building on the State Office
Park South uh the design is um in
progress currently and we we will be
bidding that out as soon as the design
work is done so that has an undetermined
completion
date um item 13 uh this is one of the
projects that relates the general Ator
so this is relocating and upgrading an
electrical service which is
current um and uh instead of upgrading
the service and then having to move it
when we installed the generator we
decided to wait and um do the two
projects together so again that one will
be completed in the
fall um the same is true for item number
14 which is another electric service on
the same campus related to again the
conquered steam conversion and the
associated generators that's for the
paint and carpentry building so that one
will also be completed in the
fall item number 15 um is
for uh we we were using the funds at
Rockingham County there's an option here
to use it at Hillsboro as well but we're
using them at Rockingham and that
project is set to be completed this
summer item number 16 uh another
Courthouse project in Rockingham
uh replacement of the HVAC pipes and
that is scheduled to be completed in
October item number
17 is for new boilers at coas County the
design of that project has been
completed and we're waiting um for
warmer weather here to shut down the
current boilers and start the
replacement
work item number 18 um is again another
uh boiler project this one is near
completion um and it will be completed
in the next few months the the funding
is entirely encumbered at this point for
the
project um item number 19 is for
emergency generators at five um of our
most susceptible Courthouse
locations and that project is scheduled
to be completed in
September item number 20 is for a
cellblock renovation at Hillsboro County
South courthouse in ashwa and that has
not yet
started I'm going to skip over
the IT project here and move on to item
number 22 which is for the bankra
building
stabilization uh that project uh design
has been completed and construction to
be started
shortly
item number 23 is another one of our
emergency fund
um this one was the emergency fund
appropriated in
2017 there's about
174,000 remaining of the original
$500,000 appropriation this is the
emergency fund that we've been using to
offset the lapsed money for the
conquered steam conversion project um I
think we talked in the original capital
budget hearing earlier this year about
the $2 million that was appropriated
part of the appropriation for the
conquered steam conversion project that
lapsed um two years ago and we found
several other uh funding resources
within the division and Department to
help offset that um the funding that we
were not able to
um to
regain um item number 2 oh that's an IT
project skip that one for
now so we're on item number 25 which is
um a roofing project for Spalding and
that one has not yet started but will be
starting uh will be going out to bid
soon item number 26 is
um a bundle of funding for security
upgrades at state-owned buildings so
this is another fund that we've been
using using on an as needed basis to
upgrade things like alarm systems um
door security card reader systems and
other things to help ensure that our
buildings are
secure um item 27 is a similar project
uh designated uh specifically for the
Health and Human Services building at 29
Haven and again we've been using that on
an as-needed basis and currently we're
um installing cameras additional card
readers um for security over there as
part of the uh pandemic um preparation
and ongoing uh security
needs item number
28 um is for the State library parit and
ceiling pair uh this project is
virtually completed but we've recently
discovered an issue that we're doing
some investigative work on and so we'd
like to retain the remaining 53,000 to
address that issue um if we need the
funding item number 29 um
is is the um one of the original
Appropriations for the conquer steam
conversion project um we intend to use
the remainder of this funding it's
currently encumbered um and will be used
to complete the remaining punch list
items for the conquered steam conversion
project which should be finishing up
here um in the next few
months item
number 30 which is um The Lodge roof
replacement on the State Office Park
South this project was again delayed due
to covid and um we'll be beginning as
soon as the weather gets nice again and
we can do Roofing
projects um item 31 is um another ada8
access this is on the backside of the
main building it's currently under under
construction um most of the fun has been
encumbered there's a small amount
remaining and that construction is
ongoing to be completed sometime in this
calendar
year item number 32 is for main building
Peasley Wing um for a roof replacement
and this project is on
hold has not been
started item number
33 is
for the Milford Circuit Courthouse um
new construction um funds that were
appropriated in 17 um the courthouse is
essentially completed an operational but
we'd like to retain the small amount of
funds remaining to complete some final
punch list
items I'm going to skip over item number
34 and number
35 and I'm going to move on to item
number 36 which is again our 2015
appropriation for emergency funds
there's about $70,000 remaining in that
um original appropriation um which we
intend to use for a back flow backflow
preventor project on the New Hampshire
Hospital campus this summer when we can
get into the ground again and do that uh
replacement work we did a temporary fix
earlier in the year um just to get us
through um but we do have intentions to
use that remainder of that funding to
complete that
project um on item number 37
um which is again another
Statewide appropriation that we use on
an as-needed basis this is for Burglar
Alarm Replacements so again in addition
to the other two
security Appropriations we continue to
use this on an as-needed
basis number 38 is for um upgrades and
repairs at the State House and the upam
Walker building which again is
predominantly spent but we have a few
small projects still outstanding that we
were are in the process of
completing item number 39 is oh that's
another IT project and um item finally
item
40 um which was originally for the main
building Bakery which has since been
torn down um we intend to use the rest
of this funding to again pave the um
back section of the main building where
we're currently constructing the Ada
access um and it would become a parking
lot with Ada accessible parking
um and we're we're tying this in with
the paving project that will also um
pave over where the temporary boiler
infrastructure previously
was I think I hit on all of them and I
know I did it rather quickly um and I
have a couple spreadsheets and Pages
open here trying to make sure I didn't
lose track of anything but please feel
free to jump in with questions and I'm
also happy to talk about the projects
that are completed um and the funding
that will
beable on item 40 do we have to
purp um so that I realized that that
funding um was originally appropriated
in 2009 which is well before I was in
this role um I think the I don't even
speak to what the intent was at the time
because I'm not sure but um since then
that portion of the building was torn
down and work to restore the backside of
main building so that safe and usable
space so I might defer to someone who
knows a little bit more or I can find
out if we need to change the purpose of
that well if is the area that we're
Paving adjacent to where the bakery was
yes it's actually right on top of where
the bakery okay I I would defer to uh to
the LBA but it sounds like we're all
right to leave that as it
is and so why don't we go over to the
commissioner
to handle the IT projects I'll go
through the IT projects relatively
quickly I I think it's it's fairly easy
there are two uh two projects that are
labeled Erp sustainability Erp is the
enterprise resource planning it means
and it's our it's the state enterprise
system the computer system um every year
there's a there's a smaller
appropriation for this in the coming
bium there's a there's an appropriation
for migration of the cloud and and the
most upgrade this project is to deal
with continual upgrades and improvements
for example uh the one was creating the
Strategic sourcing module and the
contract management mod
module um and then uh working on wfm
which is a which is a the timekeeping
portion of it um and and some
interfaces um a lot of that work was
suspended during the uh during the
pandemic um for example strategic
sourcing we got you know probably a year
ago March well a year ago um we were in
a in a great place um and then we
stopped because everybody working on it
has been working literally for the last
year on on pandemic stuff particularly
in the procurement shop which is where
that's that's been LED what it means is
there's there's more money there than
uh uh than there should be so both of
those have remaining balances but both
of it is simply because the work hasn't
been done the work will be done over the
next year and two pieces of it anyway
incorporated into the um the project
that's on your 21 list as the cloud
project um which is uh much more than
just going to the cloud but is actually
the the next generation of the
system um so that money is is uh used
for that as well um to make sure we're
not going to um redo the work so both of
those are we still
need
um there's a there's a scheduling
project the Erp scheduling SCH software
was a uh was a project that um started
and stopped again in 2017 and 201
18 um because of a bad vendor a
difficult relationship with a vendor I
don't know if I'm allowed to say bad
vendor um which we uh which we
sidetracked and then is up and running
but um Corrections is where that started
started um that's likely to go live um
at the end of this month um and then the
next two phases which are also um 2477
scheduling bits I believe our safety and
then I know safety is two I think New
Hampshire hospital is three but don't
hold me to that but um um that money
will support that that project which
we're actually very optimistic about um
and then the the the third thing is the
the one that has about $300,000 left in
it which
project that actually dates back to
2011 um this is probably the last time
you're going to see this um we actually
anticipated using that this year um the
department has not uh been allocated it
money in the state operating budget
because we have this it project left
over from when the when the phase two of
the original ARP was implemented the H
side of it um the HR and payroll side of
it if you will um the idea was to
upgrade our our system we hads then and
the idea was to upgrade them we did
upgrade some we still have a lot of old
computers now we have something like 21
units don't hold me to that number
because that's probably give or take 10
that are um at least five years old and
doit has us on a fouryear build
back um we had a computer purchase
scheduled for April a year ago and we
didn't do it because when we were
stopping doing things like building
stuff and fixing the treads on the
stairway at the department of safety
building for example um I decided that
we weren't going to buy new computers
and so but now we're gonna buy new
computers but we didn't before and we we
probably won't uh spend that before the
end of the fiscal year but we'll spend
it before the end of the calendar
year that's
it okay any questions for the
Department seeing none the bottom line
is we have 40 Projects they should uh uh
let's see Mr
Shay uh repres Jack I think you would
want um Karen to go through the projects
they've completed there's any laps
available that you could
repurpose okay uh because there are
projects that aren't listed on the laps
extension that they worked on through
this bium that they may have some
leftover
funds all right why don't we do
that sure if I may I have a a list here
of projects that are
complete
um starting
with um an appropriation from
2017 um for Statewide energy projects um
that money has been fully spent so there
is no lapse
there I have an appropriation from
2017 for a roof replacement at the
department of safety there is $ 75,4 196
left in that
appropriation I have a project
appropriated in 2017 for a roof
replacement at the Walker building and
there's $
22,35 remaining in that
appropriation I have an appropriation
from 2017 to convert the administrator
Administrative Office of the courts into
the new probate court and
conquered that project is complete and
there's $1
149,90
remaining I have an appropriation from
2017 for the Supreme Court roof
repair um that project is complete
there's
$1,445 remaining in that appropriation
also from
2017 um the new courthouse that was
constructed in Hampton there's
$3,767 remaining in that
account the next two are roof
Replacements from 2017 one in Portsmouth
and one in Rochester at the cour houses
the
Portsmouth um appropriation has
$16,995 remaining the Rochester one has
$26,670
79,2 190 remaining um there was a a
request to um use that money for
something I believe um that was in
legislation last year and I don't think
that it through the process I don't know
where that stands at this point in time
um but that money is currently still um
in that capital
account that's it that's it good one to
end on that's a good one to
end yeah I think we're all happy that
the conquered cour house project
completed
successfully yes it's a beautiful
building it really
is for those who weren't on the
committee at the time uh we used a
private contractor to build the building
and then sell it to the county which is
not the way we normally do building
projects and it was kind of
controversial at the time uh and it was
a little bit risky because they were
building it right next to the existing
Courthouse while they trying to have
court so that's the background on that
uh I see a question from representative
Mills uh yes thank you Mr chair uh I've
been going through my paperwork and
trying to keep up with countless emails
we've got on all this do we have any uh
written record of all these lapses that
we have money coming back from and if so
where do we have it yeah I was just
going to ask that if we could get
uh if we're going to be able to reuse
this we need you know a massive amount
of text uh to put into house B25 for the
repurpose uh and we don't and uh uh
let's see Mr Shay apparently knows
that uh thank you R Sam Jack now that
the Department's identified which
projects they're completed with I have I
can get the information in terms of the
value of each of those projects and put
together the language you would need to
repurpose okay that would be
great and I'd be happy to send that list
over because that's a substantial amount
yeah that is a substantial amount of
money particularly in the in the marac
county courthouse very very pleasant
also Mr chair I noticed in past years
we're used to dealing with maybe
getting maybe two $300,000 left over for
projects and this this seemed to be a
very uh nice boost in the revenue
side
so I see no further
questions uh anything uh anything else
the department wants to
add um thanks thanks for having us and
if you have any other questions as you
go on we're um we're always available
and happy to be here all right well we
certainly thank you for doing such a
nice job and the bottom line is we have
40 out of 40 Projects that should be
continued and we have money left over uh
and we'll get the list on
that thank you thanks have a great day
let's see if we and because we've
noticed the meeting the way we have we
are able to continue with the next
agency which is uh
Transportation I do not see the
commissioner yet but that doesn't mean
that
we uh can someone from Transportation
say who's going to
present yes representative um Chris was
Tru Deputy Commissioner I was going to
present this information with Mar Mullen
um and she she's not on as of yet she's
coming on now wonderful there she is it
takes a few seconds when we do it for it
actually to transfer
over so that's why there can be a little
bit do you want uh Patrick Hurley
on or anyone else no um Bill Cass is
with us as well he's he's the assistant
commissioner all right let me just tell
everyone where we are we're on the
Department of
Transportation uh that's on worksheet
page 12 starting at item
155 and by my
calculation uh all of their projects
should uh there's no project that that
can be lack at this time from the ones
that are listed so with that uh we'll
recognize the we'll recognize Mr
was uh to go
ahead and thank you representative and
members of uh house public works
subcommittee for the record Chris
waschuk um the Deputy Commissioner of
the department um so um I believe Marie
sent um an 11-page document and she's
sharing the screen right now with the
description of I believe there's roughly
25 or 30 or so projects um that date
back several
bienniums um that were awarded Capital
that were approved with capital Bud F so
I I will I will go through this fairly
quickly I'll I'll pause after each item
if if that is okay for any questions um
and then we can move on um I will say at
the start a lot of um most of projects
were impacted by covid you know frankly
when covid happened last spring um we we
took a pause on some of the capital work
because of because of the the state of
the highway fund revenue and our concern
that the revenues coming in um would
potentially impact our ability to
progress some of these because as as you
know
um majority of these projects are
matched with with um Highway fund um
there are a few that I'll I'll talk
about that are General
funded majority are Highway funded so
the first one here um
and it's 14 um
.155 it is it is in in essence the 5%
match for the um Federal um Aviation
program really as as we talk last
Wednesday um although the initial
appropriation is shown at 77.6 million
that is the total funding which includes
the federal and state and I believe the
local portion uh this program um in
essence is funded with 90% FAA funds uh
for airport improvements 5% share is is
funded with the state general fund and
then 5% um is a local share you know
a lot a lot of this program hinges with
um faas Regional and National priorities
um although there were probably some
some delays relative to to covid I think
the majority of the delays were you know
had to do with um faa's priorities in in
moving various projects forward um
typically um when funding is available
um you know to let me let me refr phrase
that typically it takes about 6 to 8
years from the time that this um capital
budget item is approved to fully expend
the funds I mean that's that's just the
nature of the program so we're
requesting a lapse extension until June
2026 um the general fund appropriation
was actually 4.1 million uh the
remaining balance at this time is 3.5
million um
and are there any questions relative to
this
item seeing
none yeah please proceed okay thank you
the next item um is also uh a general
funded item this this is um State a
accounting unit
1337 it was actually $1 million that was
allocated were approved for uh railroad
Bridges um that are on
um active active Rail lines um in
essence this funding was frozen again
due to co impacts on Revenue um as you
know the department has over 100 over
160 state-owned Bridges railroad bridges
on just the active lines um and these
bridges are inspected annually um
that a common has identified over 20
structures that are listed as a category
CI and that is a category in the
inspection program that Identify some
sort of defect or repair that will be
needed within approximately one year so
in essence um we are still moving
forward with this these items these
um we're requesting we we feel we can
expend These funds by June of 2022 so
we're requesting an extension until that
time any questions on this item yeah
let's go ahead I I'll let you know if
there's a question absolutely okay um
the next the next item uh item 133
accounting unit um
1338 these were this is actually um an
appropriation 900,000 for a private rail
line uh the project completion date in
an AUD AUST um based on a
G&C um item is uh August of 2022 so by
that time we feel that this this work
would be completed so the extension is
requested out until August of
2022 next
item this is also um a similar private
rail line request um this actually is a
request for the stra and County uh and
cow county rail improvements $900,000
appropriation similar based on um a GNC
item um the feeling is that this one
here will be uh completed by August of
2021 so we request an extension until
that
time now please uh please
uh let's go unless I see a question uh
let's just move from one to the next
absolutely next item is um matching
funds for federal the federal uh Transit
program uh these are these are 10%
matching funds um the appropriation was
97,000 uh typically um it requires at
least 18 months to secure vehicles um
this is to leverage 80% federal funds um
it utilizes 10% local funds and then uh
the 7,000 was a 10% match for that for
that effort um right now uh because of
because of some delays because of covid
we're expecting that we would need an
extension out to June of
2023 next
item um this this is a Highway funded
item this was accounting unit
1344 it was for State equipment it was a
10 million um appropriation
we have roughly 2.6 million left um we
did freeze um any kind of purchases last
last year so we do expect um to utilize
These funds so we're requesting an
extension until June of
2023 the next item the Manchester Patrol
shed another Highway funded item 2.1
million was appropriated for the design
and construction C of this um as we
talked about uh this item last last
Wednesday um additional million dollars
of appropriation will be necessary uh to
be able to fully fund this item this
this project was bid last spring um the
bids were open and they were much higher
than the
appropriation so in essence we need um a
lapse extension as well as there was
discussion about needing another million
for this item and we have that noted on
a separate
page the next item is uh also a highway
funded item D Bryant
system this is actually well underway we
did pause it a little bit because of the
covid um issue but we are moving forward
and we feel that this item will be fully
extended by October this year so so
we're requesting an lapse extension
until um October of
2021 the next item um Statewide Life
Safety
Code improvements $4.1
million um this was also put on pause
because of covid um we feel we need an
lapse extension until uh December of
2022 to be able to fully progress on
this item and address um fire the State
Fire Marshalls issues at um a number of
our shed
locations the next item uh is 1.8
million for Statewide salt
sheds as we talked about this is this is
an annual item that um is appropriated
to address the worst of uh Statewide
salt sheds that we have due to co again
we put uh halt on some of the design and
construction work locations in mil and
dixville are moving forward um with this
item and we feel this work can be
completed by June of 2022 so we're
requesting extension until that
time the next item Lancaster district
office
Edition similarly uh due to co we kind
of took a pause um we feel that um this
item can be can be completed by December
of
2022 and we're requesting an extension
until that time in addition to this item
this item will need another
$450,000 as we discussed last Wednesday
in order to fully fund and complete this
work based on updated
estimates the next item is a state
ground uh State W excuse me Statewide
underground fuel tank replacement
program it's typically an annual program
um um a biannual program appropriation
of two a little over $2
million um
again we did take a pause we have
several several uh projects that we are
moving forward with uh to be able to
utilize this appropriation and we feel
that U by December of
2022 this item will uh will be expended
so we need an extension till that
time I apologize my phone is ringing ex
excuse me for one
second I apologize it's my house home
phone the next item a New Hampshire
document management uh Software System 1
million was appropriated for for that
item um right now we're working with
theit and there's substantial changes
going on for various systems um with a
roll out of Microsoft teams and
SharePoint
so until
those those um systems are fully
understood we request till June of
2023 um to be able to address this
item the next item work water uh system
phase the first phase uh this item is
well under way we have a vendor asset
Works um in place there were some minor
delays early last year with the
cancellation of travel and such but this
this uh project is moving forward and
the apartment request um an extension
until June of
2023 um to be able to fully act on this
item the next
item Statewide equipment purchases This
was um an appropriation in just year
19 there there is
$214,000 that was appropriated I believe
it was a transfer from other items that
lapsed funds so we request an extension
till June of 2023 to be able to F fully
utilize and expend These
funds the next item is similar to uh an
item that we I spoke of earlier um it's
really for the FAA program um
80% federal funds 10% uh State matching
funds um this item um again in order to
uh fully utilize the funds that
typically take 6 to8 years so we're
requesting an extension until June of
2022 the next item um is a general
funded item it was uh $500,000
appropriation to repair archers in
walpool uh these archers were large
Granite um historic Arch culets that has
some flood damage and undermining uh
because of covid and different different
issues with permitting and and getting
uh work started out here um we're
requesting that this be extended until
December of this year in in order to
address um those issues this work is
being done inh house um but we feel that
we can complete this work by December of
this year next
item this is an airport Improvement
project uh for the easn slope railroad
uh excuse me Eastern Slope Regional
Airport 75,000 appropriation this
airport is located in Fry uh fryberg
uh it's kind of complicated from a
funding standpoint it does have this
general fund uh capital budget
appropriation and then it recently
received Grant funds from FAA the main
do USDA and so on so the department
plans to make a one-time payment once
the project is done and project
completion is scheduled for um July of
2023 so we we feel that we can expend it
by
that June of 2023
date um next project is the lisman
project it's a patrol shed project This
Is A Highway funded project um this is
just about fully complete however there
was a last minute change during
construction that required um handicap
access so this extension out to February
of 22 will address that and and utilize
the
Remain the next project is the
underground tank replacement program
um 1 million was appropriated back in
2017 uh for this item there is roughly
325,000 remaining again due to covid and
other issues we feel that
um we need an extension out until
December of 2022 to fully uh be able to
uh expend the the these These funds uh
we
have two projects that are currently um
waiting to to be bid and once they go to
construction probably use some of these
funds the next item is um a salt shed
program 1.7 million at that time was
appropriate in 2017 we have 161,000
remaining um again we feel an extension
out until November of 22 is necessary to
fully expend These
funds the next item Manchester Patrol
shed uh this is an item that was o
discussed last Wednesday this is
actually for $300,000 for design um we
are going to this was bid last spring we
are going to rebid so we need these
funds to uh be able to do some file
design work to address Fire Marshall uh
comments as well as get the project
ready to be rebid so we feel that uh in
August extension up to August of 20 22
is necessary um for this
item um xville Patrol
shed this is another item where um 1.4
million was appropriated an additional
700,000 is needed this this project is
actually bid twice and put on hold um on
both loc both um instances due to covid
as well as increased
costs uh this so
this additional uh this this work in
essence is is anticipative completed by
November of
22 um so it laps an extension out until
that time is necessary to continue uh
with this
project and with that I'm going to turn
it over to Marie to um talk through um
the final remaining projects Marie
morning uh members of the committee so
um some of these projects here are going
to be a little more repetitive um uh
because they we have multiple items so
again here is our from 2015 is our FAA
program U of the amount appropriated um
what you're seeing above here is is the
federal and state funds uh but down here
we have the general fund initially
appropriated was about 3.6 million we
still about 1.6 million remaining um for
match for the federal FAA program again
that's uh the state's share of that is a
5% match so we'd like to bring that
forward
the next item are are some funds for
railroad Bridges uh we have a small
balance remaining of 122,000 as Chris
stated before uh we have approximately
21 in that C1 condition so we'd like to
um you know we plan to continue to
utilize These funds to work on those
railroad Bridges and um bring them back
into um a good present
condition then next item is line 180 in
hb25 um these are public transit funds
uh for the the match for the bus program
so this is the state's 10% match um
there there is a balance remaining here
that we would like to continue to
utilize um for the uh 11 public transit
agencies to provide the state's 10%
match on bus purchases um moving
forward the underground fuel tank
replacement again this is additional
funds as part of that program so there's
about 49,000 remaining plus some
encumbered funds that we'd like to bring
forward to continue to utilize um and be
able to put out as many projects as we
can on this underground fuel tank
replacement
program next item is the oversized
overweight permit software um this
project went out to RFP has been
implemented and there are some uh
additional funds here 200,000 for um
annual maintenance and hosting costs um
those should be um utilized and
completed by August of 2022 so we'd like
to bring that forward to ensure that
those funds will be utilized on that
project as
intended the next item is Line 183 in
hb25 and that is uh related to the
welcome
centers uh these funds were initially
appropriated at 760,000 there's still a
$242,000 balance remaining um we've had
to put on hold some of the
repairs um Rel at several of the the
sites due to um turnover of personel at
both do and Bea um and then of course
covid with the funding issues um the
intent is to utilize the majority of
these funds on the Littleton site
restrooms and uh then um the subs the
remaining funds would be used for
additional repairs at several of the
other uh sites throughout the
state line 184 is the 5% match again for
the FAA program um with this one there
of this amount there was 1.6 nearly 1.7
million of General funds appropriated uh
the remaining balance is
96,000 um again as Chris mentioned some
of these projects can take six to years
to complete so we'd like to um bring
forward the balance here to be able to
complete those FAA
projects line 185 um is railroad
acquisition right of first refusal so uh
185 and 186 are both similar um in state
law it requires us to be able to um have
the first right of refusal for rail
properties and uh airport properties
within 90 days of them of them being
offered to the state so these funds are
needed to be able to be brought forward
so that we can meet that 90day
requirement um otherwise you know the if
we didn't have these available you know
we don't have this in the operating
budget it wouldn't be available and we
wouldn't be able to meet that 90-day
requirement so we we'd like to continue
to bring these balances
forward and then page nine are just some
footnotes uh page 10 uh these are the
three projects with um laps funds that
are available so as you can see so you
know not a lot of money here um but $57
related to general fund and then these
two a little over 11,000 related to
Highway fund projects uh we do have a
few other projects that were lapsing but
they have been fully expended so these
were the only ones that had uh funding
remaining now if we can go back to the
previous slide I'd like to just explain
something the the one before that okay
uh if you take a look for example at uh
line 184 the 5% match the reason why you
have the same projects coming back and
back and back this particular one was
first appropriated in 2013 and then it
would have been extended in 2015 and 17
and 19 and you'll have another
appropriation in in 15 that was that was
extended in 17 and 19 and we have one in
in this year so they pull all that money
together and we simply use the money
until it's fully expended so that's why
in case anyone is confused by that
that's why you see the same item come
back several
times that's correct thank you
representative
Jack uh so our last slide I believe you
saw on Wednesday but I'll turn it over
to Chris um if there's any questions on
that or if we want to revisit that
discussion at
all so so representative so this this
slide was shown on Wednesday so the
there are three previously appropriated
items that um as we noted on Wednesday
they require additional funds um
primarily because um they were either
bid last spring and costs came in much
higher and with the Bureau of Public
Works really evaluating the cost today
they feel that the cost 10 to 20% higher
than they were even last spring so uh
like for example Manchester an
additional million dollars is needed uh
for that project for the Lancaster
district office an additional 450,000 is
needed for that item and the dixville um
patrol Shar an additional 700,000 is
needed for that item which total is 2.15
million we also noted that um the fuel
management system that is currently in
our current budget request we feel um a
million doll reduction to that 5 million
initial appropriation um would be would
be adequate so the net change really um
I don't know if this is a decision
before this committee or the entire
Public Works committee um an additional
1.15 million is needed yeah well that
part I can answer uh this this committee
will simply report back what it finds
it's up to the full committee to make a
final
disposition uh according to whatever it
wishes to do
thank you
representative and I see representative
Mills has a
question yes thank you Mr chair uh I I
agree that this this request should go
in front of the entire committee not the
laps committee but I did want to bring
up while we have people here um to Mr
Shay I believe we've already seen uh
you've crafted an amendment to hb25
regarding this is that correct sir that
is correct repm Mills and I just uh
shared it with repm Graham and he asked
all the committee at it and it was based
on the idea that um I brought up at the
presentation the other day of creating a
new appropriation in House Bill 25 for
these three projects and reducing um as
showing as shown here on the sheet the
million dollars from the fuel management
system replacement project that's in the
request so you okay thank thank you very
much thank
you so I see no further
questions uh was there anything else you
you wanted to
cover that that's that's all we have
Representatives
um so the bottom is we have 32 uh
extensions and they stay in there and we
have the the one item to make additional
Appropriations uh that was on that last
slide
correct so that uh if there's nothing
further that you want to say uh I guess
we can move on let me see thank you I
have thank you thank you representative
apprciate your your attention well thank
you for all your good work
that was a nice
presentation that you put together and
it's h it's smooth as silk when
everything in house bu 25 is the way it
should be thank you have much
appreciated so
let's what I'm going to do is I'm G to
bring
on uh DHHS and if they can tell me if
they want to proceed now they're not not
scheduled until 10:30 so if Lori Weaver
can tell
us as soon as she gets
on if she wants to go
now representative Jack yeah when I this
is Chris when I reached out to the I let
them know that this was a a flowing time
in the there was a tentative time that
they would be scheduled but potentially
you'd be going 15 20 minutes earlier
than that so I think most agencies
yeah well the thing is I yeah I mean at
some point I want to fill in with the
written
responses uh if we have a if we have a
break in between at some
point uh we had uh we had sever many
agencies uh if you look in the U there's
a there's a Consolidated uh I don't know
compendium of the written responses that
Mr Shay sent out a day or two ago that
you should find in in your in your email
somewhere and uh we can we'll go through
that uh at the
time at at a time when we have a either
have a
break uh in between
agencies or however that's going to
work I don't see Lori Weaver is not
responding
to my request that she come on so um
does anyone need a moment to look for
that
so the Community
College had three
projects they issued a
memo on the 8th of March uh they have 41
42 and 43 on page four of the
worksheet and they want all of them to
be
extended so we have that the Department
of Education had two
projects that's on worksheet page five
at 56 to
57 and they should both
stay the department of energy and
planning had one project page five item
58 and that should
stay fish and game this is on uh
worksheet six item 74 4 and
75 and they want them to
continue uh the judicial
branch uh had a presentation of
Christopher
keing uh they have it's on page 9 104
105 and 106 and they want them to be uh
continued and
then the legislative branch has our
favorite project the uh that's on page 9
item 107 they want that to
continue uh the
PDA this is an email of Gino Marone on
the 2nd of March and the 3D of March uh
item 140 they authorized to
lapse with nothing remaining item 141
they authorized to laps I assume you
have
those
uh Mr
Shay and then 142 and 143 they want to
continue the
Dr has one project page 12 item 144 and
they want that to
continue police standards page 12 item
145 memo of John Skipper on the 9th of
March 145 should
stay the department of
State uh page 12 item
154 uh this is email of Dave scandin on
the 9th of March and they want that to
stay University
system uh page 15 item
187 uh the presentation of the 10th of
March and they emailed on the 2nd of
March uh and we discussed this when they
were in uh with their main presentation
187 is authorized to lapse with nothing
remaining
and then the veterans
home uh which is four projects the
presentation of 19th of February and an
email of Margaret lre the commant on the
2nd of
March uh 188 189 and 191 should stay in
there 190 is authorized to lapse with
$1,646
remaining so that
completes the
uh responses that we got in
writing and uh so that that's
done and we if if Lori Weaver could
let's see what is wrong with my
mouse
so there you are so uh so DHHS are you
ready to begin and is there anyone else
that you need on the call yes good
morning uh Dave weers needs to be
brought over I just gave him a heads up
that we're a little early uh and he
should be joining any second okay he's
on there now um bring him over Mary kise
if you want Mary kise and Karen rounds
please Mary and Karen well see do we
have a Karen so Karen may not be there
just yet but if Mary's there she's I
mean we're running a little early so uh
if we need to uh wait a few minutes we
can do that I just I took the
opportunity to uh we we got several
agencies responded in writing where they
had very few lapses uh and so I've just
gone through that with the
committee so that part is done okay um I
just gave a heads up to Karen she should
be joining any minute but I think
started all right uh I will I will uh
just to orient the committee we are on
uh we we are on work worksheet page six
uh starting at item
76 and you're going to find that the uh
order that the Department's presentation
is in is not the order that house bill
25 is in so as they go through I will
give you the item number which I derived
by
hand so if you want to begin uh please
do thank
you um Dave you wanna do the
first slide after that so good morning
and thank you for having us this morning
we have U myself my name is Lori Weber
I'm the Deputy Commissioner of the
Department of Health and Human Services
and joining us we have uh Dave clap
who's our director of facilities and
Dave weers who is our director of
Information Services which represent the
bulk of the projects that we'll be
talking about this morning uh we also
have Mary clis and Karen rounds um our
finance and Deputy Finance chief officer
joining us uh this morning Dave next
slide so I will just do a quick
highlevel summary and then going to turn
it over and we're going to toggle back
and forth between the daes if you will
um so that we have our projects uh
categorized as things that we have uh
completed to date and things that um are
still in
progress so right now we have out of the
28 Uh current capital projects in play
we have six of them completed and we'll
go over that in detail with you in just
a moment um and out of the TW remaining
28 we have 22 remaining that are
currently in progress so our schedule
laps for completed project projects at
the end of this fiscal year would be
about
3,418
and66 so the next slides go through um
our completed uh projects um and they
toggle back and forth so the first one
here is the New Hampshire hospital which
is the acute Psychiatric Services repair
Renovations uh Dave clap do you want to
speak to this one
sure hello Representatives um my name is
Dave clap I'm director of facilities
toat Health and Human
Services uh the hospital APS repair
Renovations there was a number of uh
upgrades that were being done uh
replacing uh leaky Windows uh repairing
the roofs uh installing a new curtain
wall and uh door Replacements and
upgrades that project has been completed
got uh completed right around uh last
year well a little over a year ago and
we did have some carryover because we
had to uh ensure completion of a couple
items that were left on punch list but
it is now complete and um can be
closed Dave do you w to do you guys want
to just pick up as the slides go which
one is
yours I think this next slide is Dave
claps the access front door release
tube no that's
yours I apologize you're right so
enhancements relative to Medicaid
Eligibility rules and processes
eligibility systems so this this project
um was completed and we're able to um
lapse the remaining amount of 9 ,
63379 um this was associated with um
changes to our new height system our
integrated eligibility system that
provides eligibility to our snap tff and
Medicaid
programs and any questions on on this
one yeah I'll let you know if I see a
question otherwise just please continue
uh from Project to project certainly so
then the next one the new heights access
front door project
um is including content management
enhancements and changes to our online
chat functionality as well as our child
support application
integration this system this project was
gold at continuing to um to as I said
earlier enhance the the new heights
integrated eligibility system um to
provide for more ease of access to forms
for clients as well as security
enhancements associated with um our our
an or biannual audit um um remediation
and um requirements so the the initial
approval was in 2015 we completed that
project and and um there's no remaining
funds so that was completed in March of
2021 this this March
actually and then the the bridges
modernization project so this initial
project uh was the first phase of
basically moving from our Legacy 23 plus
plus year old system and into the the
into a comprehensive child welfare
information system it is the first phase
of a six-year um project um there was
some delays in the project overall but
we completed that work last May and then
we we're continuing you'll see later on
the the the next the next phase of the
child the comprehensive child welfare
information system um commonly known as
bridges in our in our children youth and
families Division and and that will be
continuing over the next several years
as
well and then the DHHS email
project this project was to implement
the Microsoft Office exchange it was the
the Department of Health and Human
Services component of migration from
Lotus Notes a legac email system into
the new the the current exchange um
email system system and that that
project was completed and we are um we
are recommending two laps the
$5,784
18487 and then moving on to our division
for children Youth and Family scanning
unit project that project was gold at
taking our paper process and and doing
an Imaging process to make those make
all our actual
manual processing of paper available in
the system electronically to alleviate
um the the casew workers having to drive
back to the office to get information
they were able to actually access that
information while they're out supporting
their
clients that that project was completed
in March 2019 and continues to be
supported in our in our class 27
operational budget in the in the DHHS
operations and then moving on to our in
progress capital projects um these are
projects that we're we going to request
that they would not be lapsed so that we
can continue the efforts and it we'll be
I'll be passing it back to Dave clap
this next one I'm going to have to uh
interrupt you before everyone to tell
the committee that this is number
93 okay um The Glen Cliff home fire and
Ada Code Compliance this project has
been going on and uh is near completion
we did Identify some additional areas
that needed um additional coverage and
that's why we're asking to have this uh
lapse extended uh for this project
um and we are expecting it to be
complete by November of this
year
this is number
86 the Glen Cliff portable water system
uh phase one is a project that's been we
being worked on very hard uh we are
asking there is we have pretty much
completed phase one and our on uh
working on phase two which is later in
the
slides um there's 8
$946 left in this project and we're
having a completion date of 2022 October
of this year uh next year where the two
projects combined um because they are
phase one and phase
two this is number
87 Glen home campus
security uh there
has been an ongoing project uh we're
expecting to get this completed in
November of this year uh was uh to
give uh security for the clients uh to
allow them
to uh be maintained and not to wander
around and uh get lost plus there was a
lot of uh upgrades within the building
to allow for the monitoring and um
wellbeing of the
clients there is an uncovered balance of
17719 that we have other identified
other areas that we are going to uh
address that weren't addressed during
the original uh
section this is number
88 glun Cliff home access tunnel repair
our repairs are been going on an ongoing
basis as has been allowed by covid uh
some areas we have discovered uh with
another project that we're in need of
being addressed so we're expecting to
have this complete by September of this
year um and right now there's an unced
balance of
12,839 62 which will be fully expended
by the time we're complete with this
project this is number
81 Glencliff home fire road and travel
rebuild uh the safety concern for the
Fire Road uh we have addressed it it has
uh been pretty going along pretty well
it was affected by covid uh deliveries
of material and um Workforce were for
the uh contractor were affected because
of uh the
covid-19 we're expecting to have this
complete by September of this
year this is
85 85 of the Glen Cliffe Lam Martin Wing
window replacement uh has gone very well
we have identified additional windows
that we had not included in the original
portion because of uh fear of not having
enough funding for them uh the funding
is there to allow us to complete the
project and get that out of uh done by
November of this year um delivery on
these is take some time because they are
customade and um the ones that we have
put in have worked very
well this is
96 that's you Dave
yep I I saw you breathing so um Again
David weers so the New Hampshire
electronic health records um project was
a was basically part of our critical
Cloud migration and so we we originally
had electronic medical record system on
premise in our doit data center and as
part of of a migration for disaster
recovery and failover capacity and in
remediation of the Legacy equipment we
allocated These funds to do that cloud
regation and it's anticipated for
completion in November 30th 2021 this
this this calendar year it has an
unencumbered balance of
35455 90 which is a associated with the
existing contract to complete the the
work this is
94 the New Hampshire APS Security and
safety
grades um this particular one is a joint
project between facilities and it and my
understanding is that it should be
completed this December of 2021 and it's
meant to basically do the renovations of
the lobby and entrance of the acute
Psychiatric Services building Dave did
you have other items on this one no
that's um there was a couple of items
that were identified that needed to be
addressed and uh they have been included
ined in the um project to be
completed this is
89 I think that's one you Dave oh
yes hure Hospital roof replacement um
the roof has been replaced we have found
that we are getting uh additional storm
water infiltration into it we are in the
process of getting that addressed and
expect to have this project complete by
December of this year right now the
unencumbered balance is
38445 U the additional work we don't
believe will leave any uh addition funds
available when we
complete this is
90 enan for Hospital chill is an
Associated component replacement the
main focus of this was the chillers and
associated components they have been
installed and up and running there is
additional work that needs we have found
that needs to be done to allow us to
ensure the uh longevity of the equipment
we expect that to be complete by May of
next year uh the unencumbered balance at
this point is
276,000 the project
complete say
91 this one's M New Hampshire electronic
health record Pharmacy and scanning
module again as we we continue to
enhance the functionality of that um
electronic medical record system we are
we are planning to have that module
complete by November of this coming of
this year November 30th 2021 as a result
of of other um critical priorities um
impacting the the division um we had a
delay on the implementation however it
was due to Resource constraints as well
as covid-19 pandemic impacts but we are
anticipating to have that completed by
November the unincumbered balance on
that is $15,452.57
new hampire hospital renovation of
existing space this is to allow us to
complete the renovations of the pharmacy
and
um psychological areas of the facility
um some of this was held up because of
covid restrictions and uh Trying to
minimize the exposure of clients to um
non um DHHS staff there is an cumbered
balance at 28
55328 and we expect all of that if not
all of it pretty close to all of that to
be um expended by the time the project
is
complete this is
83 New Hampshire hospital air handling
system upgrades this
was truly affected quite uh heavily by
covid uh we couldn't do a lot of the
work that was
required uh because of requiring us to
have proper air ventilation and so forth
so we do have an the project is as you
can see almost fully expended the money
is
encumbered um but it has not been
expended and we do not expect it to be
complete until January of next
year this is
78 Glen Cliff Home Electrical enhan uh
system enhancement as most people know
the Glen Cliff is a standalone system up
there and we are have been working on
this to get going forward the project
has been bid it is in the process of
going to GNC for a uh to be awarded um
so all the funds will be expended um by
the completion which you expect to be
June of uh next
year this is
77 Glen Cliff home portable water system
phase two this ties into the previous
one which was phase one uh this was
adding um additional water capacity and
getting us off of a SST that Dees does
not like us to use we the project is
pretty much designed at 90% and work has
begun uh work stopped last year because
of frost but we were impacted by um
covid where they couldn't get enough uh
workers to get the work
completed um
the there is will be a project the going
to GNC for approval and all the funds
will be expected expended at that time
which we expect to be October of next
year this is
84 the automated inline mailing system
is what we call the as machine it
handles the mail bulk mailing for the
whole department uh we have had a uh the
project is going well uh we do have some
additional programming that needs to be
uh done the scope has been defied and
we're awaiting uh Bureau of Information
Services approval on the uh programming
and the vendor to get it
complete the there is an unencumbered
balance at this time at
13555 um we will expect that to be fully
expended when this is complete which is
expected to be in December of this
year this is
95 so the new heights incremental
mization project as you as you can see
the new height system is a very complex
system that we have had several capital
projects and we will continue to as we
continue to provide integrated
eligibility this this phase two of the
incremental renewal of new heights
allowed us to move from an older
technology of cobalt programming to a
newer Java technology and that project
is on track to complete in September of
this year of this year and it has an
unincumbered balance of
$449,500
29 that would be anticipated to um be be
um expended by the by that completion
date this project also is um go at
getting us off of um dependent on Legacy
IBM software which will reduce our cost
our operational cost going
forward this is
97 uh replay platform of options
application the options application also
are known as our elderly adult care
system that that project was um
initially approved in 2011 based off
some organizational changes and how that
that Bureau interacts with Medicaid um
we had to change from change directions
and we're actually waiting on the the
comprehensive child welfare information
system to build the build out the
platform on Salesforce so we can
leverage that platform going forward and
reduce our our overall long-term costs
of that system the unencumber balance of
of the appropriation is the full amount
$722,500 the estimated a completion date
based off of its integration with our
other um comprehensive Child Care
welfare information um system is June of
this is
76 and leading into the comprehensive
child welfare information system this
this project was the the second phase of
a multi-year project this project was in
intended on building the intake and the
assessment tools of the Child Welfare
information system where where people
our case workers will be able to intake
information from reports and then assess
those those reports and then and then
integrate in with our current Legacy
system for case management and
Reporting this project is anticipated to
be completed by September
2023 and the unincumbered balance of 7,9
24352 as a direct result of the vendor
um the contract with the vendor
indicates that they would not be paid
until they actually complete the work um
however they have done a lot of work on
the project to constitute components of
this payment and so we would anticipate
that full amount to be expended upon
completion in September
2023 this is
79 the the Medicaid management
information system or commonly known as
mismis technical stack upgrade was the
first component of a long a five-year
program to implement the changes
necessary to com to maintain that system
was focused on the Legacy Hardware that
was originally acquired in
2007 and replacing that Hardware so that
we could not only have a supported
system but also maintain Federal
certification which um is directly
related to our federal funding match for
that system the anticipated completion
date for that project is August of
20121 the current unencumbered balance
is
$322,700 which would be anticipated to
be expended upon
completion this is
80 so the the Bureau of Developmental
Services um it remediation plan this
project is focused on the the Legacy
system that is uh supporting
developmental services and there's a
typo at the top it's actually the Bureau
of Developmental services so the a would
need to be removed um that um Bas is a
different um Bureau within Behavioral
Health
specifically um this project was
basically intended to take that system
and integrate in with the new heights as
well as the Medicaid management
information system and REM remove us
from uh access database and Excel
spreadsheets into um tools that are not
man that are not creating manual
processes and potential data data
integrity and accuracy issues this
project is um in progress and is set to
complete in June 2023 and it's tied to
other capital projects that are being
submitted and and reviewed by the
committee for for future work as well
the UN encumbered balance of
3,579
777 would be anticipated to be expended
upon
completion
this is
82 and the new heights and New Hampshire
easy Gateway
monitorization that that Gateway is
basically the the integration component
of where our clients interface with our
our call center and how our call center
and case managers interface with the
clients so it's it's key um automation
for that comp those components to ensure
that the the case workers and the people
the call takers as well as the clients
are getting timely information
associated with their their requests and
verification of their
eligibility this this pro project is in
progress um this is one of the projects
that was um delayed specifically due to
the covid-19 pandemic as we took the
resources that were working on this
project and had to reallocate them to
look at the eligibility impacts um to
our citizens to ensure that as as things
changed to ensure that they had access
to the system the systems and services
that they needed they anticipate
completion um date of this project is
September 30th 2021 and the unencumbered
balance is
386,000
$262.50 and would be expected to be
expended upon work
completion and that is our last slide so
I'll hand it back to Deputy Commissioner
sh Lori
Weaver thank you so that is what we have
uh for uh it clo finished and in current
process so bottom line I see no
questions bottom line is we have 22
projects they all match to House Bill 25
albe it in a radically different order
uh this is a great example of why having
a
presentation uh in advance is helpful
because uh I was able to uh correlate
them to House Bill 25 which I wouldn't
have been able to do if we didn't have
it so if there's ever a lesson in that
this is it uh and then we have so we
have 22 projects they're all in House
Bill 25 we have $335,000 Plus in
completed projects and uh I see no
questions there anything else that the
department wishes to
say thank you we thank you for coming
and uh
that was
great day let's see so we have I have
Dees here let's bring them
on so Dees is the next agency and if I
can get my mouse to
work uh this is starting on page
five at item
59 there is a mistake which we will get
to or there's a missing line is what it
is again this was is another case where
it was really helpful to have the
presentation uh so let's
bring so Mr Scott is there anyone else
that you would like to have on the call
and we're running a little early so uh
is there anyone else you'd like to have
on the call yes uh Sue Carlson our chief
operating officer
okay just a second it does it takes a
second to move someone so they don't
show up for a few seconds there she
is's I can close the shade a little bit
if it's too if you can't see me no
that's fine um when we come to it
uh there is a
mistake there's a missing line in House
Bill
25 so
uh we can get to that when when the time
comes did you want to share the
presentation up on the screen or or how
did you want to do this we weren't
playing on that I just want to ensure
that all the the committee subcommittee
members uh have have a copy of what we
provided is is that the case uh they
probably do but if you have it available
to share that would be good
too okay you're going to challenge me
here sukin is that something you can
do uh commissioner Scott this is cret I
can throw it up on the screen if you
want please do thank you sorry would be
wonderful
yes one second
should be seeing it now yes
yes okay please proceed and I'll let you
know if uh please go continue on and if
I see a question I'll let you know okay
well thank you uh members of the
subcommittee uh again I'm Bob Scott uh
commissioner with the Department of
Environmental Services uh I've asked as
as you could as you know our chief
operating officer Susan Carlson we do
have following if need to bring them on
some of our staff members uh if there
are questions also so we should
hopefully we'll be able to answer any
questions you have uh as you see on the
screen and hopefully you have uh Sue
Carlson provided a nice memo on our uh
the lapses that are uh indicated uh laps
extension requests excuse me that are uh
indicated in House Bill
25 uh I do want to make sure at the end
of our memo uh that we do have a request
to repurpose so I want to make sure I I
draw your attention to that that uh so I
I can walk through the memo uh if that's
the chair would like or questions I
don't know how press for time you are
and that type of thing oh we're we're
running early we have plenty of time so
if you could walk through it that would
be great okay so uh pressing on well
obviously you're uh you where we
identified is the the the the sections
of the lines and house the the house
bill 25 that are uh in the lap section
of of that so uh the first section we're
talking about is as you see is our
hazardous waste uh match uh as you're
likely aware uh Appropriations are
currently being used for to cover our
the state's obligation for 10 the the
10% match from the state for uh superf
fund sites that the state has now uh
moved into the state's uh perview uh the
two we're talking in this case are NRA
plating and miramac and the
Savage uh well in Milford uh again uh
the federal government
takes a 90% share but we're required to
match uh
10% uh
and that's what that first uh section is
on our hazers waste match uh and and if
you can scroll down Chris so the the
next section is is uh again similar in
that it's matched for federal monies is
our drinking water revolving Loan Fund
so that requires a 20% match uh to the
federal part of our capitalization Grant
uh and again there's uh two major
components uh loans for infrastructure
projects in the set as size which are
the earmarks for things like
Administration and and the technical
assistance and program management that
are are listed in the the
memo uh so given the the time lag
between the Monies uh being obligated
and these uh projects to be fully
completed uh that drives a need for a
lapse extension okay so this is where
the mistake is uh the reference to 65 is
a mistake 65 is a clean water
appropriation right so we need to add a
line uh referencing 228 call one uh
roman8
B uh repres Jack yes this is Chris yeah
um Sue emailed me this morning and I
just haven't had a chance to send it
forward but um that project is complete
the uh 228 colon one oh okay Roman 8B
it's just it's just a typo okay so that
means that this reference to section 65
should just simply not be on this and
there's no additional fund there's no
additional drinking water funds from
17 yeah and I apologize for that I
mistakes happen there and I forgot to
take it off yeah mistakes happen as long
as we catch them it's not an
issue and to be fair to sue Carlson she
told me to mention it too but I didn't
get that far yet so thank you
okay uh so uh moving on so the next
section Chris uh is for the Clean Water
uh srf uh and again
just cont intuitive to some people
obviously drinking water is water we
drink clean water is is waste water and
storm water that type thing so this just
a term of art that the federal
government uses uh so this is very
similar in that we have a 20% match
requirement uh to be uh I I mentioned
the timeline lag required to get these
projects done for Wastewater projects uh
the time uh lag is even more these are
more complex projects that take even
more uh time to get from uh design all
the way through to uh operational uh so
that's that's uh the need and the reason
for for uh those numbers and again
obviously any questions you have please
interrupt me uh so moving if moving down
if there's no questions on
that uh the next um multiple sections
all have to do with our our dam
obligations uh for dams obligations for
dams I have to be careful how we say
that I suppose um and uh again this this
section 59 is for Dam repairs and
reconstruction ruction uh we have
summary uh you know between covid and
and other uh similar delays uh we do
expect to be able to obligate as as seen
on the next page August is there thank
you Chris uh the uh the next nine months
we should be able to obligate the rest
of the balance uh what we're looking at
particularly is reconstruction of uh the
weeks pond dam in Warren uh and the H
Reservoir Dam in in Harrisville so
that's the you know again we we need
that to lapse uh in order to meet that
obligation but that shouldn't take too
long beyond that um so moving to item 60
here which is our operational uh
facility so
uh beg my uh Indulgence for a m beg your
indulgent for a moment so our existing
facility is uh first of all it's very
old and and has many structural problems
but second of all it's in a flood plane
so this is the facility where we would
stage our equipment uh and be able to
grab it in case of an emergency among
other things and a lot of the damn work
we do uh having it in the flood plan is
probably not a great idea in my opinion
uh for things you need to do during a
flood uh but any case uh there's a lot
of reasons why that needed to be
upgraded so uh that we are uh out forbid
uh right now and we expect to to be at
the governor and counc for approval for
the contract for that construction in
April uh and we hope to have the the uh
the building uh in place uh in
operational uh within a year so uh
that's the those two items are are for
that uh Lake op Dam uh we've had a
fairly successful uh bium uh getting
that damn I was going to say replacement
that's actually not true we uh at the
Barry Bay at the the the end of the the
dam end of the lake uh was in need of
replacement we actually had a sink hole
in front of it if you will uh and we're
able to use the old Dam as a coffer Dam
and install a new dam right right in
front of it uh and that that work is
basically done as far as the dam goes
however we need to finish things such
such as the uh pedestrial control system
so we can automate mate uh and then make
the dam a little bit more efficient and
did then do some uh modific is Upstream
to look at the flow in the in the dam uh
but I will point out that's I think that
was a very successful project and uh you
may remember from past discussions you
know it had but for that we'd have to
drain the empowerment and uh we're
talking like a seven feet reduction in
the the uh water level of Lake op which
I don't think uh would be very tolerable
for many um the next section uh is dams
that are under our natural resource
conservation Service uh program so uh
this is uh again the the Dorchester Dam
uh is one of the dester dams was what
we're talking about here uh the the good
news is the feds pay for a good chunk of
this but we're responsible for 35% of
The Rehabilitation
cost the good news is they cover 100% of
planning design and a lot of the
engineering that's need needed to do uh
but that's why that lapss is needed to
ensure uh right now we're waiting that
can be done we're we're right now we're
we're waiting for the natural resource
conservation service to finalize uh
their Award of fed Federal fund so we
can proceed uh but we expect that
hopefully fairly soon uh so that's
that's the reason for that that laps
extension is is
requested section 70 is uh many of you
will remember some years back the
Suncook uh River jumped its bank and uh
changed its flow for I think roughly
what one and a half miles uh so there
was a lot of work done on that you can
see it as you drive on routs four uh
right across the bridge in Epsom uh that
work was done and then what we found was
there was uh a lot of stabilization
issues uh with that that work on the
banking uh it was very complex work and
in difficult uh situation there so
there's a need to maintain uh
and Laps get an extension on that lapse
uh while we continue to and the contract
uh continues to uh do assessment and
monitoring and and uh and do any
emergency construction uh services to
keep that uh working as it should and we
expect that to to last through 2023 as
the memo
says and
then we'll move ahead to our section 72
thanks Chris
um so we still have additional work
needed on uh our air monitoring
equipment in this is is is already done
but we but in this item here we need
additional work uh on the uh the backend
systems of our it uh systems and that
that'll be an ongoing discussion I think
uh including on Tuesday uh that's what
that's about so much of that work the
original appropriation has been done but
we still have some some remaining
uh similar uh similarly on Section
32 uh we have uh this has to do with it
upgrades e permitting and
automation uh we have a remainder in our
capital budget of $998,000 uh we're
asking to be carried forward uh and uh
we're we're programming that into our
pools program so our Pools and Spa
program uh which is Housing Department
of Environmental Services uh and in the
wake of I think it was two years ago now
we had a a unfortunately we had a raft
of of a legionaire uh disease uh deaths
in Hampton from from a a spa so that uh
understandably that made us look again
at our rules uh and how that's working
so we've we've revamped our rules but we
also uh are developing a computer-based
uh application system for uh inspections
and monitoring of that program so that's
what we're asking that lapse to do uh
and then moving uh to section
64 uh we have work uh that we hope to be
completed by this fall on uh pcao River
Region uh this has to do with the Great
Bay and uh we've been working very
closely with the U communities and the
Environmental Protection Agency on their
Federal non uh National pollution
discharge elimination system their nipy
uh permits uh in this particular case
for EPA is for nitrogen uh but but uh
this work will help uh the region and
the municipalities to meet their
statutory obligations uh with the
federal requirements uh so that's what
that uh laps uh extension request is for
uh the next section uh 73 has to do with
the w basaki River basin
again uh we the state owns and operates
uh that uh Wastewater Treatment Facility
in
Frankin with collection systems
throughout 10 communities uh in The
Lakes Region uh that uh their Capital uh
Improvement plan uh lays out the work
that needs to be done this this uh work
uh just to point out is not something
that would be bonded uh all all this is
paid for by the member
communities and lastly as I mentioned
probably the the thing that's I guess
the thing that's new would be new is we
do are asking that we are allowed to
repurpose uh
funds uh from uh our former hazard waste
uh site uh funds to uh use for coastal
flooding uh a modeling study that we
would like to see done uh that allows us
to uh better react and better prepare
for uh flood plane Management on the
coast uh so we we we are asking for that
so I just wanted to that's probably our
biggest thing I want to draw your
attention to uh and we're certainly
happy to uh answer any questions on that
and then the very final thing is then
that of course there's uh about
$224,000 uh from the super fund match
that we're not asking to be lapsed so so
happy any questions of course I I see a
question from representative Edgar uh
but just as an initial matter before I
recognize representative Edgar uh this
committee is a fact finding committee we
won't be making a decision on that uh
what we'll be doing is presenting the
fact that you want it to the full
committee and they will make the
decision and with that representative
Edgar uh thank you Mr chairman uh and
thanks for the answer on this there was
an issue that um that you had put into
the governor which he hadn't uh approved
it was the sixth I guess the six sixth
item on your list and it was three parts
and the third part was this uh flood
modeling um which I think was in the
range of
350,000 is this the issue that you're uh
trying to address with this uh with this
161,000 yeah this would be part of part
of that issue that's correct so you
would still need the the balance of that
if in fact this was uh uh this this was
agreed to by the whole committee
uh if you so desire right so obviously
we had a prioritized list and and that
was lower than some of the other things
but yes what I think you're asking is
disc cover that whole ask and the answer
is obviously as you say we had a larger
ask in that that party party list but
this would
go this by applying this uh laps
reapplying this repurposing excuse me uh
these funds uh that would put us in a
much better place and and uh that's why
we're asking for
that shair if I do a followup quick
please uh thank you um so the again the
original request you had for this
particular modeling was
350 thousand and this would apply you
saying this would apply if in fact it
was approved by the committee for 161 of
it would you still need I guess the
balance so that you could do the whole
modeling study so I again going to let
gonna let Sue Sue help me here but so
there there were multiple components of
that ask one of them uh was for mercury
go ahead Sue um yeah uh representative
Edgar good morning um what we did was we
looked at the 350,000 for the for the
modeling and we felt U what we could do
if all we could get was the 161 is we
would do um a partial start of the
modeling with this funds and then for
the next bium ask for the balance to
finish the modeling so essentially we
would phase the modeling um into two
pieces in order to F fit the funding
that we were given thank
you is that it Mike I have a question
about the very last sentence the 224,000
uh it's not clear to me why you have no
lapse extension Authority uh we we could
uh what's the source of funds and
couldn't we give you laps extension
Authority
um this is Susan Carlson again
essentially we were given an
appropriation back um in 2007 we
encumbered 100% of the
funds and what we did was we rolled the
encumbrance forward from year to year oh
we never asked for a lapse extension on
this because the funds were fully
encumbered oh okay got
it so you're actually lapsing zero
because they're fully encumbered well we
the the this was a particular match to a
particular EPA superf fund site and
since um that site is now no
longer um a super frun site it's now
under State Control this match money is
no longer needed so we unencumbered the
balance of 224,000 and this balance will
lapse what I'm trying to get at is could
we repurpose that
$224,000 or is it gone because it wasn't
extended is repres Jack I believe I'm
sorry Sue I was
justad um so in House Bill 25 the
appropriation was never extended because
it had been incumbered so they don't
have the Authority there there's nothing
to continue the the
appropriation uh because it was never
extended back in 2011 or or 13 whatever
the year was um so it will lapse at the
end of this year unlike other projects
that if you look at the 2019 House Bill
25 there was a lapse extension granted
right so then you would if there's
something left at the end of this bium
related to those projects that were
extended lapses we could repurpose that
right that's what I thought but I just
wanted to be sure because I didn't
really know there's not enough
information in this sentence to
understand all of that no and and and
it's I'm glad the department put it in
there because there may be a couple of
other um Appropriations that agencies
mentioned to the committee that they
believe could be repurposed I'm in the
process of reviewing um House Bill 25s
to see if they really carried forward
the laps extension authorities right I
think in some cases what has happened is
that they've encumbered the the money in
a prior fiscal year maybe it was related
to a contract or something and and once
the project completed um after cleanup
you know they had an amount that would
wasn't expended and and that with no
lapse extension Authority would just go
back up naturally yeah that happens
every time correct yeah the one final
comment I'll make is it was really
helpful to have this presentation ahead
of
time even if it was
only a brief amount ahead of time
because of the the cross correlation
that needed to be done so there's an
example of why to uh send the committee
your presentation ahead of
time and we'll try next time to get it
to you even sooner yeah was there
anything further that you wanted to say
I don't see any questions from the
committee
I just I I think i' say is thank you oh
well thank you for coming uh it's always
a pleasure and uh we'll as we said we'll
take that uh repurpose request to the
committee and uh uh there's probably at
least one person on the committee who
who would really like to see that
happen thank you representative egar
thank you very
much so let's see what we have I do not
see the next agency so at this point uh
I do not see the next agency they are
not scheduled until
11:20 so this seems like a great time to
take a break uh remember that the mics
are on we have when we're fully remote
like this we have have no way of turning
them
[Music]
off
e
for
yeah Mr Marino just let you know what's
happening uh we um gave the committee uh
we finished a little early on the
previous agency so I gave the committee
a break until
11:20
so we'll start back up at
11:20 uh can you hear
me yes we can okay thank
you
e
for
the hour being 11:20 uh let's reconvene
with the Department of Natural and
cultural Affairs uh this is on worksheet
page 10 item
125 and if you would proceed that would
be
great good
morning thank you uh my name is Chris
Marino I'm the chief of administration
for the Department of Natural and
cultural resources I'm accompanied by
Tom Mansfield our Department architect
and the master of the details of many of
these
projects um we come to you today uh
identifying uh the list of of projects
that we wish to extend laps uh for uh
with the exception of two which I have
identified uh items number 134 and
138 uh 134 uh being um completed having
no no money to actually lapse and item
number 138 uh Mount Washington
Communications building study uh which
we are complete have completed uh 47,7
193 to
lapse the rest of the projects that we
have on this list we do intend to
continue to carry um as long as we can
as long as we can to to proceed with in
some cases moving forward with the
actual projects and other cases
completing what we've already started uh
and I'm sure Tom would be happy to
answer any questions relative to those
details um with that said uh we also do
have uh four projects um lapsing at the
end of this fiscal year uh with a sum
total of approximately
and without further Ado um we are happy
to answer any questions you may have
well I see no
questions
uh and
uh right I see no questions uh I I have
no uh was there anything further you
wanted to
say uh for my part no I I will defer to
my colleague
Tom uh unless this question on the list
I think that states our position we can
certainly talk about any particular
project if you wanted us to elaborate on
them uh no the main thing we need to
find out is whether the list in House
Bill 25 is correct and it is with the
two lapses with the two deletions
noted so I think that's what we need to
know very well thank you for coming it's
always a
pleasure thank you very well thank you
yeah I see that
the
agitant person is here so let's bring
the agant
over let's see
here so the agant is the Department of I
um it's now the department of military
Affairs and veteran services uh it's on
page nine starting at
114 morning for the welcome Mr Perry
always a pleasure I have to say it's a
little unnerving that we don't have
agitant right there at the top like we
always
did yes sir it's now it's the uh
Department as you say the department of
military Affairs and veteran services
and it's good I had my uh I had my back
ination uh from from your guys so that
was great yeah I hope it I hope it went
very well we've been getting a lot of
good feedback from the operation yes it
did they asked me if I had any questions
I said where's General
mtis he is uh he is currently in he
sends his regrets he is currently at a
senior assistant training program uh for
General officers with the National Guard
Bureau and he'll be back into the state
on Monday yeah we always enjoy seeing
seeing the general uh so they have 13
iions uh they're a little bit out of
order with respect to their numbers uh
and I did find two lines that we need to
add so if you however you want to
proceed if you want to go item by
item
uh is it's your preference I can go in
the item number in the bill as
introduced I can just but I'll bounce
around on the letter that we have so
whatever me have in front of them I'll
follow that order maybe if Mr Shay could
share the presentation
and I'll do what I did before and
transfer the line and and uh translate
the line
numbers you see it now yes we do all
righty so just direct me as you uh would
like moreen as we go along all right
this this item is Line
120 that's correct so this is is uh this
really is a hazard remediation at our
facility in Pembrook uh this line of
accounting was frozen uh when covid
started in terms of the governor's
ability to allow us to spend our our uh
our Capital Money uh it is a two-part
process one is the investigation line we
anticipate that that line of that to
conduct the investigation of any hazards
that are on that facility would be done
uh in the winter of 21 and then
intermediation that has to be done would
be done by the winter of 22 we request
that this uh be uh be extended it is uh
as you can see 100% general
fund next one is
114 so this is uh for the aviation
Readiness uh facility that we have 100%
federal funds uh we have uh we have
given a notice to proceed uh we we
anticipate that they're going to ground
break ground very very soon in April uh
and we'll be able to spend the rest of
that money and complete that project in
the spring of
2022 this is
115 uh this is uh for federal and state
repairs part of this is for uh the uh a
renovation of our maintenance facility
uh it's in the renovation is under
construction we anticipate this spring
completing that piece and then there are
several projects uh uh to get after
maintenance uh roof Replacements
flooring all those kinds of things uh
that we will uh uh we complete as the
federal funds continue to uh to funnel
into the system again 100% federal funds
here so we really you know it's not not
not a burden on the state actually kind
of wifall for the state for the rest of
that 1212
million this is
116 uh we did award the design we're
going to we anticipate uh for this uh uh
it's a maintenance shop in Littleton
that we're going to build uh adjacent to
the Readiness Center that's there uh we
have awarded the design uh well we'll
award the design for that uh after the
April GNC meeting approves our piece we
anticipate that construction will be
complete on that facility in uh in 2023
fiscal year
2023 this is
117 uh this uh 117 also is impacted by
covid uh we it's a 50-50 money that uh
that we have uh the first and the reason
it was impacted by covid is because the
original bids exceeded the budget so
we're going and then we had a freeze on
spending any more of our Capital Money
based on the pandemic we anticipate that
we'll be able to continue to work
through these projects through the
summer of 2022 again uh this is this is
a 5050 account though uh it and it gets
after uh making sure that we have the
appropriate anti-terrorism Force
protection standards met uh in our
facilities next one
is8 so what we did with this one is uh
we because this is a 7525 project right
you can see it say 75% federal funds and
25% uh General funds we were able to to
swap uh some 100% federally funded
projects with the federal money that we
had and push this one down so that we
would mitigate the impact of covid on
the state so we adjusted the timeline uh
and that's why you're seeing a delay
here it's on hold for a design project
now in 2023 with construction in
2025 uh and we anticipate completing the
construction uh in 2026 so you know
because we had some 100% federally
reimbursed projects that we could move
up in the in the timeline we were able
to kind of delay this a little bit and
kind of mitigate the impact on on the
state next one is
119 like uh another this is a Aviation
Hangar Bay uh we're still pending
additional budget efforts by the
department of safety uh you may remember
that this project is a joint project
between our Aviation facility and the
state police Aviation facility uh we
anticipate that we'll get this uh when
safety gets their their budgeting
aligned to be able to complete this in
next one needs to be added that's
correct it is uh it is just minor
military construction uh and we would
like this added into the list uh we are
it's just punch list items on a $5
million project that we had we
anticipate this fall being able to close
this one out what we don't want to do is
uh lapse this money uh and and not have
something come up in the in the
contingency items of the contract uh to
uh uh to be able to address them before
we get all the punch list work done on
that project yeah there's no issue with
ADD adding a line we do it all the time
when we find things are
missing uh the next item is uh number
124 y so this is this is money that
we've had for a while to purchase land
we were in the process of completing a
purchase and sale agreement last March
uh for a parcel in Franklin when we were
told hey ceas and assist spending the
capital money because we didn't know
what the impact would be uh we are uh we
are based on our our recommended budget
our capital budget we are researching
whether or not it's good to purchase
that land we' already gone after or to
look for a new parcel so uh we
anticipate by the end of the Fall a year
from now we'll be able to liquidate this
money but it's it's uh it's really
important that we have money in a land
account uh because we can't get Federal
funding to construct facilities without
land so that's why that one is
important now the next item also needs
to be added that's correct so this is a
design ARR in the center in Pembrook uh
and again this is punch list items here
right so the next three items are kind
of linked uh this one is not in and we'd
like it added it's punch list items for
100% Federal part of the newly designed
and newly constructed uh Rus Center we
have in Pembrook adjacent to the ectc so
we're just working through the punch
list items on that want to have that
contingency available to us the next two
lines are also associated with that
Readiness Center this is line line 121
the next two it right so you can see
them uh the one that's listed 15 one six
and some zeros and 1962 and some zeros
are both uh linked so the state active
duty Annex really is to support the the
equipment and the facilities when the
governor orders the National Guard into
to State uh active duty that's 100%
generally funded and the other piece is
the actual Readiness Center itself and
again that construction is complete and
those uh the lapsed uh the unencumbered
balances really are just to make sure we
have contingency for uh for punch list
items as they go and we should be able
to close those out in in the coming
months you know certainly by the end of
the federal fiscal year next item is
122 122 is again for our Readiness
Center uh that's going to be adjacent to
our Aviation facility again uh uh the
current balance of unencumbered is is a
a small amount of money we're working
through the design and uh in
construction is in process we anticipate
that being done in uh in
2022 and last item is
124 right so again this is another one
of the items that was impacted by uh
covid uh we were in the process of of uh
of award in a contract to do
archaeological surveys at the Veteran
Cemetery uh this is important because as
we continue to fill up the Veteran
Cemetery we need to develop the
undeveloped areas of the cemetery So
currently only 20 of the 60 developable
areas are uh are are developed
essentially we can bury people there by
conducting this archaeological survey we
can prep the remaining 40 acres of area
so that we can award contact uh contract
for expansion uh in the future without
having to worry about the archaeological
surveys again we were you know when Co
hit we were awarding the contract we
stopped and now we're in the process of
working that again it's not a lot of
money but uh but doing it now will sync
our ability to expand with the timing
that the federal government and the
Veterans Administration Awards us uh
expansion uh funds so that's uh that
goes through the list I can pause here
and answer any questions about any of
those uh any of those items yeah I don't
see any questions right at the moment so
let's see the
general the big item there so there's a
couple big items uh they're 100% Federal
the 87 the one that's 87,000 is that so
50% of that would be
General yes okay so we do have we have
some money there we could
use uh most of it being Federal we
wouldn't be able to and the Statewide
Fire is also 50% so there's some money
there yes all
right I see no questions was there
anything that you wanted to add it's
always a pleasure to see the
adant it's always a pleasure to be here
uh if there are no questions we just uh
we appreciate your continued support uh
to the National Guard uh as you know
I'll just give you a a quick snapshot
about
780 men and women are still supporting
the missions uh in support of the the
pandemic and uh they're very proud to do
so and they're very proud to serve the
people of New Hampshire so anying any
questions you have that's all I have sir
I know for a fact that the Civil Air
Patrol was very uh uh pleased with the
building with the training building that
they held an have held a couple of
events
in
yes and we're happy to support them as
well sir yeah and with that I guess uh
that's going to be it for the
agent thank you sir have a great day
yeah thank you for
coming and with
that uh let's see here so that's it for
agencies before lunch our next agency is
Department of Corrections scheduled in
at 1 o'clock
so we will be in recess until unless
someone wants to say anything we'll be
in recess until then and remember the
mics are
live
e
for
now commissioner Hanks I told the
committee we were in recess till 1 so
we'll we'll start in about 10
minutes
e
right the hour being approximately
1:00
uh we would be allowed to start welcome
commissioner good afternoon I wanted to
make sure I was not muted you're there
my name is Helen Hanks I'm the
commissioner of the Department of
Corrections for the record yeah let me
just let me just Orient the committee uh
we're on uh page four at item 44 for the
Department of Corrections
uh with me is John Hansen our
administrative
Logistics and if it serves the pleasure
of the committee I will share my screen
and put our PowerPoint up that I sent
earlier uh last earlier in the week that
would be excellent uh please go ahead
and continue and if there's a question
I'll uh
I'll notice it and let you
know okay otherwise you can just
continue from item to item fantastic
sure I did
this okay so we're reviewing our uh
lapse dates on projects on page two
you'll see the appropriation associated
with our perimeter security and fence
detection system that uh project had
been on hold the completion date is
determined um hoping to go out to bid uh
and we have an amount not to exceed of
1.5 uh if you're okay I'll go
approximate since you have the full
numbers in front of you 1.5
million uh we are working on number two
the kitchen renovation at the 4.32 Mark
uh we've been working uh through several
facets of that project and currently
right now waiting for the Department of
Justice approval on the design agreement
which I did sign uh this week I think
we're past we're past that phase I
signed that this week and three copies
went
out
uh on number three that's the replace
electrical systems and that's in design
we're hoping to have that completed uh
this calendar year in December of 2021
at
265k on page three you'll see our
generator replacement of two generators
it's in the procurement process with the
Department of admin services and we're
hoping again to complete that this
calendar year by December of
2021 at
300K
the Berlin project uh the work has
started that's the access Perimeter Road
number five with the appropriation at uh
721 we have an amount not to expend at
635 that was delayed um in the North
Country at our North Country facility
due to weather but that project is
expected to be completed uh by November
of
2021 number uh six from 2019 is one of
the Appropriations for the door
replacement projects that we have
remitted in this committee has supported
in the past um that's more complex than
it sounds uh we expect to have that um
the work start in May of 2021 uh with a
completion date of June of
2022 and certainly have John available
to explain that completion date because
it seems further out than we would
otherwise expect um if that serves the
pleasure of the
committee
on keep going on number 10 you'll see
that's electronic controls and the
security camera
installation uh that goes part and
parcel with number 11 we're trying to
maximize the technology the it
infrastructure and the outlay in the the
current um modus of cameras and body
alarm manown system so those two
projects I missed a
page all right sorry
boy do I miss in-person meetings can I
just tell you all that I'm sure you do
as well let's go back to number
seven on page
four the uh appropriation for our
transitional work center to do a
complete bathroom replacement that
project uh had been on hold um we're
waiting and waiting to move forward on
that to go out to bid we did have some
work done um with regard to design and
and review of that infrastructure prior
to covid-19 and sort of the slow that
created within the logistics world so
that project is a total appropriation of
488 uh
21582 the uh number eight is our medium
custody North and medium custy South
bathrooms within the New Hampshire state
prison for men um where we did have some
delays and spits and and starts with
regard to that because of covid-19 and
having units under quarantine but we've
been working with the
uh approved vendor the bid award has
happened and we're hoping to start work
as soon as next month with a completion
date of 20121 that'll that'll really uh
improve the bathroom situation in those
two units with a total not to exceed
appropriation of 587 924 with 84
C uh number nine is another door
replacement for men's uh you know we
certainly are working with the
Appropriations to replace numerous doors
uh and that appropriation is not to
exceed of
$93,000 so as I sped ahead on number 10
uh and 11 started speaking to those uh
John if you want to comment I know we've
made some movement in that area on
projects 10 and 11 thank you
commissioner so both those projects
actually the bids close this Wednesday
the March 10th 2 o' BS came in reviewed
them and as of about an hour ago
actually actually we have agreed with
all the numbers on that so that one will
move forward to GNC those are the two
projects that we combin the body L and
the camera systems so that is now a go
finally after a couple of hiccups with
the
contracts and then on number 12 that was
for
the FF for the new women's prison uh we
still have some small uh not to exceed
amounts of the
$3,310 68 just buttoning up some FF and
in that
area making sure I don't scroll past my
pages on slide six these are the same
numbers I presented during the last uh
discussion of projects scheduled to
lapse June 30
2021 um and the dates and times for
those projects including the stee line
injector at the New Hampshire state
prison for
men uh do the additional dollars
associated with the women's prison and
uh the removal and replacement of two
oil tanks and one diesel tank the
elevator replacement project which
occurred both at Men's and within the
secure psychiatric unit and then the
secure housing unit door control system
with a total lapse of those projects of
$2,849
55 so with that um I wasn't able to
understand on the on the women's prison
uh you want to you want to extend that
even though you think it'll be complete
just on the theory that you might have a
bill coming in
later speaking are you referencing 12 uh
item 12 yes so item 12 that's that's the
remainder there's only a very small am
money left in that we've obviously gone
through a little over two years now with
that facility and this is a about three
or $4,000 actually only left in this um
this amount of money now and we will be
expending that very soon I would think
with next month or two so do you want to
extend that or or not extend
it I believe we're going to extend it
before June of 2021 so we won't be
extending it okay so we will delete uh
our item number 55 your item number 12
from House Bill 25 is that
correct yes thank you sorry for that
confusion okay
great that's what we're here for
appreciate it
uh see any questions from the committee
I don't see any uh was there anything
you wanted to
say anything you want to add John um the
only thing I wanted to add Mr chairman
is that this week has been a flurry of
activity because we've had the all the
projects open up now there were many on
hold and if you see how some of those
dates go back quite ways that's because
with Co there was some restrictions and
we couldn't get some things off the
ground but starting as up Tuesday of
this week we've really seen quite a bit
of activity from public works and things
are moving forward very nicely yeah well
that's certainly been true of every
agency that the work was slowed down
that's why we have a lot of laps
extensions this year but uh with that we
thank you for coming in it's always a
pleasure it's always a pleasure to see
Corrections and we all have fond
memories of visiting the women's prison
well we look forward to uh letting you
all come into the other facilities when
things get closer to uh whatever The New
Normal is and I thank my favorite part
was the corrections quality rocking
chair it is an interesting piece of
furniture thank you everyone right thank
you for coming all
right so our next agency is going to be
safety who I am bringing on
now there you
are where' he
go there he is all right so uh let me
just Orient the committee this is uh
we're on page 12 item 146 and this is
the Department of
Safety so if you wanted to go ahead that
would be
great okay good afternoon um Steve Lavoy
I'm the director of administration uh
for the Department of Safety um I do
believe um assistant commissioner Rick
Bailey is
also all right oh he he got moved before
I had a chance to do it there you go
morning Mr chairman uh as Steve said I'm
Rick Bailey assistant commissioner here
at the department of safety um I believe
you all have the handout that Steve team
has put together well if we could have
Mr Shay if you don't have it handy if we
could have Mr Shay put it up that would
be good that way we can follow along all
right I can see it so so why don't you
just go ahead from item to item if
there's a question I'll let you know
okay on page two is a list of all the
items uh but with your concurrence we'll
move to page three where we start to
discuss them individually right and I
will let Steve take the lead on
that thanks commissioner so the first
item which is line 146 um in in the
budget bill this is the fire academy
hbac upgrade um this is a project that
we had some delays I'm sure you've heard
other agencies have had delays as well
um but they were also some unexpected um
latent conditions that were discovered
which has um resulted in some increased
costs this was originally uh uh going to
fund three components one was replacing
boilers secondly uh building management
system for all the fire academy
facilities and third replace a vehicle
exhaust system uh because of the cost of
the boiler which has been replaced and
the associated piping um with that
project um we're no longer able to
complete all three uh we have found
operating funds to uh replace the
exhaust system in the firehouse um so
that leaves the building management
system upgrade um we do have some
additional funds available in a project
the next project that I'll speak to
74,000 remaining um and so we will be
asking the committee to consider
allowing us to repurpose that $74,000
from the next project back into this
HVAC upgrade to allow us to complete the
building management component of
that the
$74,000 comes from um the next project
which is on line 147 this is the
replacement of the fire Academy's ladder
truck uh this was a 22-year old uh
ladder truck that um has been used in
training operations uh it's entirely
manual um analog equipment and the uh
profession has moved towards digital
controls and so we need to make sure
that we are training our firefighters
with updated equipment uh that truck has
been uh purchased the purchase order in
place it's being it will be built and we
expect it will be delivered in April of
2022 and so since we know the cost of
that vehicle um there's
$74,000 remaining in that capital budget
line um and this is the 74,000 we'd
asked to repurpose to the other fire
academy projects so we can complete the
HVAC project and I do have some uh
proposed language at the end of the
presentation um if that's something the
committee would like to consider uh
looking
at the next project we have is line 148
this is to create a criminal records
portal really two phases two steps to
this the first is uh allowing
individuals to schedule their
fingerprint appointments online and then
phase two would allow individuals to
request and receive their criminal
history records online um the phase one
development is is complete at this point
and we've moved into user acceptance
testing uh we expect phase one to be
fully implemented by June uh phase two
development and implementation will will
follow once we've completed that that
first implementation and we expect the
project to be completed by January of
2022 the next project is The Troop C
renovation uh Troop C is the state
police uh troop facility in Keen it was
built in
1981 uh and the renovation includes
replacing the hfac system and completely
remodeling um the internals of the
facility to meet current operational
needs um that project design is complete
and the request for proposals is was
released and we're expecting bids uh
next week for a bid opening on March
17th and so that's continuing to move
forward the next project line 151 is an
online customer portal for the DMV uh
and this continues the DMV's move
towards processing online transactions
whenever possible and so this project
would um redesign the existing online
onine transactions but then also create
online transactions for duplicate driver
licenses driver history reports and then
driver license restoration fees the um
several of those elements including the
duplicate driver license have been
developed um and uh they're expected to
go live by June of 2021 uh there's
additional development business
validation and go live for um the the
driver uh restoration fee pay payments
that's outstanding but will be expect to
be completed by the end of December and
then we have the design and pilot of
electronic lean and title processing
which is the next phase of that
project the next is a um records
management system for uh the state
police this is really their primary um
piece of software that they record all
of their case management analytics
reporting it also includes computerated
dispatch functions this is in
development and nearly complete um user
acceptance testing is will be starting
very shortly and training and
implementation follow we're expecting a
July uh July time frame for
implementation uh the next project is
the n e911 Next Generation upgrade um
this is to upgrade the state's 911
system to uh the Next Generation
standards and protocols uh that's a this
is a long-term project it's a
significant project um we've got large
portions have been already completed
successfully including upgrading the
core Network um to meet the standards
moving to an IP based network instead of
just a plain old telephone line systems
um but there's additional requirements
to um standardize our GIS system that's
the gra geographic information systems
um and also call Handling Systems on how
those calls come in and are handled
within this with within the 911 system
itself and the expected completion date
of this project is May of
2022 um the next item is within lines 12
and 13 of the budget um this is already
within uh hb25 so this isn't a this is
this is language that's already existing
and this would be to repurpose funds
from an existing radio interoperability
project to the state police hanger
project which was approved through the
last bium um the the costs exceeded the
original estimates uh for the State
Police hanger um fortunately there are
these funds available to us that we no
longer need within the radio
interoperability project and they're
very close to what we need to complete
the hangar project so if we repurpose
These funds we believe we'll be
successful in completing that
project um finally uh this last page
goes back to the request for the
committee um to to repurpose $74,000
from the fire truck within the fire
academy uh within the division of fire
standards and training to repurpose that
to the fire academy hvap project um this
is just some some proposed language uh
that we believe would achieve that um
but that's important for us to complete
otherwise we won't be able to um to to
complete the HVAC project we've already
absorbed some of that cost with
operating funds as I mentioned for the
um for the exhaust system in the
firehouse um but with this additional
74,000 we believe that we can complete
the building maintenance system
installation and upgrade as
well and that concludes our presentation
we'd be open for any questions that you
may have so the way the repurpose is
going to work this is a fact finding
committee uh not a decision-making
committee so what we'll do is we'll
bring forward the fact that you want the
repurpose uh to the full committee uh
and the language of course is helpful
and the full committee will decide what
to
do very good we appreciate it and I see
no questions uh was there anything
further you wanted to
add uh no I think we're all set okay uh
if that's the case we can unshare and uh
thank you for
coming thank you very much our next uh
our next agency is doit I don't see them
on there yet let's see when they it's
17 they're not scheduled until
1:40 which is 20 minutes from
now uh would the committee's pleasure be
to take a 20 minute
recess all right we'll be in recess
until uh
140 and the mics are
live
e
Happ
for
e
let's
[Music]
see
so we can start in just a couple seconds
uh representative query if you're
there yes okay why don't we
begin and uh welcome commissioner
go the committee uh just for the
committee uh we're on doit it's page8 at
item
98 well good afternoon members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Dennis goule I'm the commissioner of the
Department of Information Technology I'm
wondering if the host would be able to
share the um the presentation we s
that's what we've been doing all day
so
great
all right well we can we can uh dispense
with this page and jump to the next page
please does the off button logo know
that you're using
it pardon me does the off does the power
button logo know that you're using
it
no all the
uh you mean my background no in the doit
the the power
button oh I don't know I don't I don't
know what you're referring to uh sorry
so please proceed when we just go
through uh you can proceed uh through
the projects and I'll let you know if
anyone has a question all right great um
we'll start out with the um ones that
were asking requesting to uh to continue
and then we'll on the final page we'll
go into the the ones that will lapse um
the first one is Enterprise workflow and
document management uh that really had
been intended to address a long-term
need to improve the efficiency of State
operations by using workflow
technology uh we when we originally
envisioned this appropriation to be
using um primarily um General workflow
Technologies like um Microsoft
SharePoint but early on in the bium once
uh we we worked with or we discovered
that um the administrative Services
folks had had some um an initiative to
implement a contract related workflow
inside our in4 Erp system some of you
may know as of the Lawson Erp system so
we we pivoted a little bit and worked
with them on that uh initiative and and
that was moving along and we actually
had some you know we had a lot of
progress on that and then the uh the
purchase of property folks have been
pretty diverted by Co they've been kind
of full heads down on acquiring um stuff
for covid response and recovery so uh we
that project's been on hold for a number
of months actually a year now right and
uh the other thing we've been doing is
piloting some some technologies with um
agencies that would help them in their
own workflow and um inside the Microsoft
suite and that is in Pilot stage now and
and and again we slowed down quite a bit
by Co activities um but we do we do know
that and believe that we can Implement
um improve our workflows another thing
that did happen in in Co that that
were're researching now in a couple
agencies the use of workflow
Technologies e signature has arisen and
so we're we're also looking into that as
a potential future thing so we would ask
that this this um committee grant us the
ability to continue with this project um
we I I believe we'd be a lot further
along had we had we not kind of diverted
you know late last or early last year
into the co response and Recovery I do
believe this money will be well spent if
if it were the will of the committee to
continue this
one um Statewide
archival this one's been again you can
see from the datea on it's been moving
fairly slowly there were really two
primary parts of this uh I think the
largest part from a legislative
perspective was the the the the
researching the uh potential use of
technology to reduce square footage
footprint for the state archist to the
Secretary of State's office the second
piece of This was um to to um look at
archival technology that would assist
again in the efficient running of state
government so we really had Envision
getting some professional help in to
help us um understand this better as
well as um Implement some tools so we
have implemented
we have a small
implementation pilot that we're in the
middle of
now and we continue to collaborate with
the AR office but the you know they've
been pretty focused on other things and
and as we so again we haven't moved this
along as quickly as I would have wanted
to or expected to but again I do believe
there's value to the state in continuing
this I'll stop on this page and see if
there's any question questions on that
let's go ahead and continue there's no
questions okay thank you um Enterprise G
GIS alignment that was U I initially
requested this um in uh in anticipation
of a passage of Statute that is now RSA
4f that created the gis committee um
part of that we did create the committee
and have been operating it ever since
and we did
come up with a number of initiatives
that would that we would work on to um
implement the legislative attent intent
of RSA
4f um and that really a quick there is
to re the legislation act that we review
the use and development and coordination
of geospatial data resources across the
state not just state government uh
consider the need for
centralization and ADV I on GIS needs um
at public and semi-public agencies so
what we've done there is initially we
came up with a gap
analysis um and the gaps where we're
looking now you know what are we doing
now and how does that not um act on
legislative intent and we've done a lot
of good things um I I could go into
those but in the interest of time I
won't but um we have proceeded pretty
far down the path of implementing
legislative intent for RSA 4f and we're
nearly out of money um sometime in the
future we may need more but um right now
I think we're in good shape for another
couple of years and we do intend to to
uh use the remainder of this balance um
right now the large project that's going
on is a um a lot of the um work we've
done in G in collaboration with the uh
Granite which is a UNH um
entity they've had for years a public
wearing hous bis data and we was getting
very long in the tooth and it wasn't
very citizen friendly so we're we're
expanding on that as well as working
more um with uh entities uh Municipal
entities and other entities to um
collaborate more on standardization of
GIS resources across the state so I
would ask that this be continued as well
and the final is uh digital government
trans transformation this was really the
real intent of this originally and and
remains was to improve our ability to
deliver CI services and provide access
to information to Citizens through our
digital Government properties websites
and applications that are projected out
to Citizens and businesses of the state
um we we have implemented um Statewide
content man management and hosting
system and standardized templates for um
for All State agencies although although
we haven't been able to implement them
for All State agencies because again um
we pivoted very quickly to covid-19 work
in this area um now it's a good thing we
it turns out it's a good thing we did
this because the volumes on our websites
in covid-19 have been uh above and
beyond anything we've ever seen before
particularly after a press conference a
governor press conference and so um but
if you're interested in seeing some of
the results of this uh two good places
to go look would be the Department of
Education website and the Department of
Environmental Services website and you
could contrast them against say the
Department of Corrections website for
example which is kind of more of the
older style and see the types of things
that that have been done so again we
haven't gotten as far along as we'd like
to and and that reflects in in the spend
there also we did a lot of covid website
work with this new um with this new
ability but a lot of that was paid for
with cares act money so again it didn't
it didn't diminish the um the balance on
this Capital
appropriation any questions on this
page okay continuity of operations is
recovery planning um just recently um
contract was approved by the executive
Council to uh to bring in a company do a
a full assessment of our Disaster
Recovery uh posture as well as help us
rewrite the doit continuity of
operations plan um
so and you will you may remember that
and and we had envisioned this as a
two-step process one by enum we do the
analysis we bring in professionals to do
the analysis the next bium we start
acting on the findings so you'll you you
may remember that there's a
appropriation request in for this bium
to begin to act on the findings of this
now certainly the our dependence on our
state it resources um continues to grow
even outside of the massive increase
that
covid-19 provided so I think this is a
important for the state this is nearly
expended now and and will be um by the
end of uh likely by the end of this bium
early early
next and then cyber security and program
enhancements um we did um what we had
expected to do on this program um in
this bium despite the fact that we were
pretty heavily diverted by a number of
things the largest thing was our um
independent cyber security risk
assessment and the um and addressing the
findings of same so we had a a really um
deep and wide assessment of our cyber
security posture that
involves um you know but all of our
infrastructure a good part of it as well
as many of the applications important
applications that we run um one public
facing result of that and some of you
may this may have impacted you was that
we actually had to bring down um
Environmental Services uh One-Stop web
uh web applications for a while because
we found some pretty serious cyber risks
there that we had to mitigate before
bringing them up so we felt really bad
about that because we were affecting
again citizens and businesses of New
Hampshire but the first the first
priority really is to protect the data
of of the citizens and businesses and so
we did that there um based on based on
the current situation we're in and the
dangers that we're seeing in in the
world um where we have a couple things
we'd like to do with the remainder of
those funds one is to uh create a uh a
set of campaigns that help train state
employees on um how not to get the state
Network ransomed basically is to be very
explicit with that the ransomware is a
huge danger and you may some of you may
have seen it in your own communities
where um you know we've seen a lot of uh
municipal government and and safety
entities in New Hampshire get ransomed
over the past two or three years um
we've been lucky at it in the state of
New Hampshire and careful but um I think
that the the criminals are getting
better and better at doing this and we
need to up our game in this um and then
the the second part is um uh to assist
us with the final configuration ofet
discoveries solution which was funded in
already had been funded in this
appropriation so we would ask that that
be moved forward as well and we we do
expect that to be completed pretty
soon any questions here no questions I
don't see anything so far all right well
I know that sometimes lapses agreeing to
lapse something is can be exciting if
there's any money left but we will lapse
all these but there really isn't a lot
there but this is the ones that will
fall off our our books uh effective
uh next by
Anyan okay that's it I see no questions
uh was there anything that you wanted to
add no just thank thank you for
consideration if you think of any
questions feel free to reach out we'll
get the
answersa okay thank you uh and we let's
move our next Agency on
here our next agency is the Liquor
Commission and it is page nine at item
108 and we have
uh chairman
Mica yes good afternoon members of the
committee hope everyone's doing well
today I'm with uh my CFO Tina deir and
we'll just run through these quickly for
you uh we're requesting to bring forward
three projects and to lapse four and
Tina will run through them quickly for
us thank
you good afternoon members of the
committee um on our presentation on page
two is our uh nextg project that we
would like to move forward can we take a
second when we get that up on the
screen there we go
my fault that was a little delayed not a
problem to Jump Right In just tell me
where you want me to be and I'll get you
there um on page two is um the uh next
gen project which we're currently in the
middle of um design and development and
starting testing we're looking to go
live with that project at the end of
this calendar
year if you want to go go
to page
five or at page six that's our Hampton
North and South project we are currently
um have gone out to bid and and
initiated a contract to um sell the
property we are going to do a um selling
of the property and using the funds that
we received for that to pay down our
debt
we have the project on page 10 which is
our conquered um it says roof
replacement and parking lot our roof is
complete but we had to delay our Park
parking lot we put that project on hold
and we're looking to back up to bid um
to start that
project and then on page 11 are our laps
projects there's the uh Chesterfield
store expansion we're lapsing 288,000
for that one
our signage and branding will be done at
this end of this uh fiscal year but
there will be no funds available in that
one there's our conquered roof which has
completed there'll be about 490,000 in
that one and then our Portsmouth store
at the Portsmith traffic circle we will
be um lapsing back about 1.1 million in
that
project yeah now these are all liquor
funds correct so they don't actually
help
us yes that is correct that's correct
before the committee gets excited about
these big
numbers and that's all we have great I
see no questions from the
committee and uh we thank you for coming
is there anything you wanted to else you
wanted to
say Enjoy the beautiful weekend we
hope enjoy thank you thank you great to
see you
very okay committee that is our last
agency
and uh what I will do I will wrap I will
roll this all everything we've learned
today into a report and I will send it
out uh as soon as I finish it if you
find a
mistake uh please let me know and Mr
Shay uh yeah thank you representative uh
Jack so what I'm what I've been working
on is compiling the um potential
projects that you can repurpose and I
think we mentioned earlier that there
are some that agencies are bringing
forward that haven't had laps extensions
in any of the capital budgets for one or
two or maybe more by enums and in the
past practice you haven't tried to
repurpose those
dollars and I've got a question out to
the comp troller if it's even um
something that could happen if there was
never a lapse extension provided right
so what happens with as we discussed
with Environmental Services sometimes an
agency encumbers the full amount they
finish the a few years later and there's
a few dollars left they didn't need a
laps extension because it was
encumbered now the money comes out and
and it's there's been nothing that said
hey there's laps there and you can do
something with it so at this point I was
um not including that in any of the
totals that I had put together so far
but based on what I've heard agencies
provide to you
um let me just get my screen up
here there's there's about $2.2 million
in dollar that you could repurpose yeah
the administrative Services was was a
nice windfall with the uh money from the
marac
court yep um so they they were a big one
Environmental Services with their
$161,000 um there's a Department of
Education had
$100,000 um they wen't an agency that
came in but their documentation provided
that
information um so yeah but you know so
so there's a fair amount of money there
um and and I'll share this with you
representative Jackson as you prepare
your um report that you're going to
share back with the committee okay just
wanted the committee to know when you
see the information I have it's only
those projects that I can find the laps
extension in 2019 okay so you're going
to send me that and I'll I'll cross
check it with what I have yep is that
right okay
yes sounds lovely any anything else from
anyone just want to say Marty good job
running the thanks definitely very
good and uh with that I guess we can be
adjourned